- Well, I don't trust Redwing.
Hold on a minute.
You don't have
to trust Redwing,
but I'm going to go
see if he's right.
I have a feeling it might
be a part of the Big Three.
What Big Three?
The Big Three.
Androids, aliens, and wizards.
That's not a thing.
That's definitely a thing.
No, it's not.
Every time we fight, we
fight one of the three.
So who are you
fighting now, Gandalf?
How do you know about Gandalf?
I read The Hobbit in 1937
when it first came out.
So, you see my point.
No.
I don't.
There are no wizards.
Doctor Strange--
--is a sorcerer.
Ha, ha.
A sorcerer is a
wizard without a hat.
Think about it, right?
I'm right.
I just-- I just
came up with that.
It's crazy.
But look that's not the point.
These guys aren't
magic, all right?
They use brute force
just like you--
the incredibly annoying
guy in front of me
with the staring problem.
I'm coming with you.
No, you're not.